is this because of some kind of
discrimination against girls and science
or simply because of the natural
inclination of girls between science and
other subjects well first of all what
we're saying is that there's no
capability gap when it comes to girls
and boys that taking science and maths
when girls study maths and science they
they do well in fact they do slightly
better than by sonu capability gap
however girls don't often see themselves
in those science technology engineering
type roles but they see themselves as
doing something caring or doing
something that's collaborative or
creative and if you then tell you that
with the align that with for example
being a chemist researcher or a
technologist or an engineer who develops
creative applications for the health
industry or medicines that really help
the whole of mankind then they see
themselves so you could we ought to
think this in a different ways what does
it what does that job look like and can
I see myself in that role what do you
think I mean does it matter if girls
don't choose or aren't encouraged to go
down the route of science and maths oh
it matters hugely it matters to the
industry to our economy I think it's
eight only eight percent of people
working in stem are women which is a
shocking statistic you know and it
matters i mean i think there was also
something in the oecd gender equality
report that was out today that i said
back to me what I mean okay I mean why
care well I tell you why they care is
that companies are screaming out for
these skills absolutely screaming out if
I just think about engineering alone
there are thirty-six thousand unfilled
jobs right now right here in the UK so
we're stymieing growth the UK economy
and we're Stein me and their potential
for girls at his personal growth as well
you know as as truly says yeah sure
Nicky that sort of a suit that treaty
talks about that sort of positioning of
girls women away from STEM careers into
other fields where's that kind of
attitude evolved from whose fault is it
what can we do well it's an attitude is
evolved in culture
we have what the scientists knew a
scientist car dealer phone calls a
culture of neuro sexism where we hold
his myths about how the male brain works
and the female brain works you know it's
truly points out there isn't any
difference it's it's a cultural
acclimation to you know encourage
certain caring nurturing skills creative
skills and women and not in men and
obviously that harms men too so I think
it's worth saying you know everybody
loses when women are not encouraged to
be equal and have equal opportunity to
take part in these careers and you know
the other thing is that aside from the
gender equality argument its economic
argument the world would benefit from
more women working in science and
technology in you know so many ways so
you might just think why do we need an
international women's day why do we need
a day just to mark half the world's
population but clearly there is a needle
sorts of error oh there is a need and I
think there's a bit of a misconception
actually around international women's
day that it is just for women I mean
sure it's to celebrate the achievements
of women and it's to highlight the
struggles of women but it's for mentor
on the stand those as well it's that
everybody to take part you know and
actually international women's day has
been going for I think since nineteen oh
eight it's sort of fell into obscurity
and it's only in the last few years it's
really had a resurgence so don't even
think the question is why we need
international women's day it's why is
there such a demand for it why is it had
this surge in popularity I mean I
suppose some men might feel well if you
know if women are kept out of the
workplace women kept at home doing
domestic chores it's better for me why
isn't it better for them do you think I
thought oh no I'm saying oh it's not
good Islamic state obviously yeah well I
believe women are allowed you no control
over their own lives there's more money
you know there's more generalized power
there's more sex to go round actually
it's Ellen tell the sex angle you know
if we will have to be empowered they
will have more choice over their
reproductive rights you know they'll
have more control of their fertility
will have a better brought up a more
intelligent next generation let me take
the boardroom for example if you're an
ambitious male executive you don't
presumably want a higher proportion of
women coming because there's well
competition if you competitive you don't
want anybody else around you male or
female let's be clear about this right
suriname look half the population out
push the women out and just play the
male game but actually research comes
out now and there's more and more coming
up that says profits and results are
better if you've got a diverse workforce
and men and women prefer a diverse
environment they have a better quality
of life when they go to work so for
everyone it's better as you said
earnings are better for the individual
they're better for the company they're
better for the country so we really
really need to make sure that we include
women this so how do we do that though
there's one says we need more one led
one of Sicarius adam says that some
perhaps you wouldn't want it but how do
you actually get to that position what
does it take that government policy is
that employers what is it for me if I
think about stem because it's been a
really good career for me I've earned a
good living I've worked with some
amazing people and I've had a family for
me it's about making sure that girls are
aware of the jobs that are out there and
that they can see themselves in those
jobs that's the first thing the second
thing is to make sure parents and
teachers and the career guidance
services are aware of the jobs of death
many of them don't many of them are
frightened that they don't know about
these new virgin in jobs and thirdly we
need companies to have a diverse
environment because that not only wealth
comes the high talent but it also keeps
the talent there okay there's not
necessarily mother you're gonna make
this argument though I mean I suppose
the reason why men historically have
been dominant was partly the whole
question of physical strength yeah there
are still some people who say well
there's a physiological difference and
that you know women aren't up to it they
can't do it like men do I mean and that
is believing quite well it's a form of
dominatrix in an amateur boxer I you
know I beg to differ and if somebody
wants to come and have a go then you
know let them I mean the difference is
now gender-wise a physical strength and
negligible these days are being serious
because it's unpossible that argument is
still being had or still being mad but I
think it's actually much more to do with
fertility it's to do with conte because
because what's always really mattered is
women's ability to produce children you
know the idea of having to keep your
women safe and in a place where you can
see them so you can guarantee the linear
you know of your children i think is
actually what it's been to do with not
physical strength but there's something
else you're right there's an there's a
power that comes with economic strength
whether that economic personal financial
were stand-in all over country if you
think about singapore singapore is going
through explosive growth and it has done
for the last thirty years they've put
huge amount into investment particularly
around the science technology
engineering math skills and what's
happened the whole economy the whole
nation has benefited that's where the
strength comes from okay lots of lessons
to be learned this is Magic wave estate
thank you very much indeed